holy [ __ ] I wanted to talk about this
trailer for a while now I just had a
really busy weekend but now I'm gonna
talk about it because there's no way I'm
not gonna talk about the trailer from
Batman Arkham Knight it's not gonna
happen I'm not skipping out on this show
this is a really good trailer it's a
great trailer by any standard movie game
TV show whatever however you want to see
it this is one of the coolest trailers
I've seen in a while this starts out
Bruce Wayne's look at all brooding
because he's Bruce Wayne
I hear Thomas Waynes last will and
testament and he's naming off a bunch of
things he's saying to Bruce Wayne in
this letter here Thomas Wayne saying I
give everything to you Bruce Wayne
please don't squander it help the people
of Gotham be the great man I wish I
could be there to see you become but
won't be there but to be a great man i
immensely love this why because it could
be taken one or two ways Bruce Wayne
really went against what Thomas Wayne
wanted him to do and became Batman or
you can see it as Bruce Wayne did
exactly what Thomas Wayne was talking
about and he took that advice and he ran
with it as Batman I love that I love the
fact that it's like Bruce Wayne's like I
think I'm doing right by my dad this is
my perception of the trailer buts one of
those things that locked me and I'm like
I love this [ __ ] and after that you see
that two-face and penguin they've teamed
up Harley Quinn's in the mix I guess the
story is after the events of Arkham City
all the criminals are banding together
and they're like let's just take Gotham
a really big Gotham a Gotham that is
apparently five times bigger than the
Arkham City got them that is insane but
hey you gotta make a bigger you got to
make it better this is all for next gen
consoles - so it's going to be bigger
and better look pretty good is this
trailer in-game I don't know if it's
in-game graphics and nothing would
surprise me after the ground zeroes
trailer you're like oh wow next-gen is
cool I like next-gen or now it's current
gen but the point is Batman gets a new
suit Batman gets a Batmobile that you
can drive around in because like I said
this entire city is five times bigger
than the Arkham City city so now you get
to drive around in the Batmobile which
is gonna be cool you know they're gonna
be upgrades you do with the Batmobile
the Batmobile is gonna do a bunch of
different [ __ ] at 'mobile is gonna be
like an extension of Batman I want my
Batmobile I was always concerned about
the concept of a new Arkham game that
took place after Arkham City because I
was like there are clearly gonna be a
few villains that might not be in there
spoiler alert if you have not played
Arkham City can tell you right now
people died in that game really key
iconic people some can be brought back
sure there are Lazarus pits and [ __ ]
others aren't going to be and I'm sad
about that however in a world
there are a few less villains they have
a new villain a brand new villain for
this game the arkham knight which makes
me go whoa you're creating villains in
shape let's hear this out tread lightly
tread lightly but then I find out that
Geoff Johns is helping create this
villain for this game I'm like okay if
you're gonna create villains in the
Batman universe make sure is created by
one of two folks Geoff Johns or Scott
Snyder any one of those two guys can
create a villain and it'll probably be
fine
Geoff Johns is one of the quintessential
comic book writers for the DC Universe
and a dude kicks ass he's the guy who
made Aquaman awesome swear to God I have
read Geoff Johns Aquaman if you haven't
read it and you will walk away going
Aquaman's awesome I'll read anything
Geoff Johns does so I'm immediately
excited about him working at any level
on Arkham Knight apparently he's back
and she's she's sexy she's Harley this
game takes place a year after Arkham
City's obviously she's not pregnant for
those of you who found the easter egg
pregnancy death so does she have the
baby is there a little Joker baby out
there somewhere and he'll become Robin
who's ever cool my joke is baby become
Robin this is the irony would be kind of
neat I'm not even gonna go there this
game takes place a year after Arkham
City the kids like a few months old max
I love the fact that Rocksteady is doing
this game this is the conclusion to the
Rocksteady Arkham game trilogy they got
Arkham origins created by another studio
which I liked
I enjoyed Arkham origins but it was
clearly a step down from Arkham City it
was cool to see Rocksteady go nope this
is our conclusion and we are back maybe
Kevin Conroy voicing Batman again I
thought the dude in Arkham City did a
really great job he sounded like young
Conroy and I have no complaints about
that but if this does take place
afterwards
Conroy's got to be back Kevin Conroy is
back as Batman I'm looking forward to
this game I expect a lot of extra [ __ ] I
expect a lot of Easter eggs a lot of
cameos this bat mega it's not even
coming out like next year anything is
coming out this October holy crap that's
awesome so the trailer for Batman Arkham
Knight have you seen it what did you
think about whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]